[MUSIC PLAYING]
NICK DE CRISTOFARO:
Hi, everyone.
My name is Nick De Cristofaro.
I'm a Customer Engineer Network
Specialist with Google Cloud,
and I'll be your presenter
today in this video.
If you started your journey
towards Google Cloud
from a hybrid
on-premesis model, it's
likely that you're already
using some hybrid connectivity
features, one of
them being Cloud VPN.
Historically, Cloud VPN
offered you an SLA of 99.9%,
and with the introduction
of our HA VPN solution,
we now offer an SLA of 99.99%.
You're able to benefit
from higher availability,
as well as ease of migration
between classic VPN and HA VPN
In this video, I will
show you how easy
it is to migrate an
existing classic VPN
tunnel to an HA solution.
First, let's look
at two migrations
path we will look at today.
The first one is migrate an
existing classic VPN solution
to HA VPN using BGP as
the routing protocol
to on-premises network or
any non Google networks.
And the second is migrate an
existing classic VPN utilizing
policy-based VPN
to HA VPN utilizing
BGP between two projects or VPC
within Google Cloud Platform.
Now, let's begin by looking
at the first example migration
path.
As you can see here, I'm in
the hybrid connectivity section
of the Google Cloud console.
Here's a tab for
VPN, and this is
where I would like to have
a look at the VPN tunnels
and the Cloud VPN gateways
that are available.
Here, you can see that I have
two classic VPN tunnels that
are already established.
If I scroll to
the right, you can
see that I have
dynamic BGP VPN tunnel,
and I have a policy
based VPN tunnel.
For the first section
of this video,
we will focus on the
demo VPN tunnel that's
already established over BGP.
The first thing you want to do
is to create a new Cloud VPN
gateway.
If I click the Cloud VPN
tab, gateway here, you
can see that I have a classic
VPN gateway with an associated
IP address, and I have an HA
VPN gateway already created.
If I click create
new VPN gateway,
this is where you would
create your new VPN
gateway for HA VPN.
You would give it a name
under the VPN gateway name
and select an appropriate VPC
network for the VPN gateway,
and these would be the same
VPC network and region that
match your current classic VPN.
My current classic VPN gateway
is configured in us-east4,
so I would select the us-east4.
I will not click Create, because
I've already created one,
but in your case, you
would click Create.
So next, if I go back to
the Cloud VPN Tunnels tab,
I'm asked to select
a VPN gateway,
and I will select the
HA VPN high availability
gateway I just created
and click Continue.
I'm presented next
with two options.
In the first example, we will
look at an on-premises or non
Google Cloud peer gateway.
I've already created a new
demo non VPN gateway, however
in your case, you would need to
click Create peer VPN gateway
and then provide a name.
In this case, it would be
the on-prem VPN gateway,
and then specify the IP
address of the interfaces
of your on-premise VPN gateway.
Now, you may have one,
two, or four interfaces,
and this depends on your
vendor's configuration.
In my test
environment, I'm going
to use two interfaces
with the same IP address.
I'm not going to enter these
right now and click Create,
because I've already done so.
I will click Cancel instead.
Instead, I will click
peer VPN gateway name
and shoot the VPN gateway
I've already created.
The next step is
to ask me what I
would like to do with high
availability component.
Now, high availability, or HA
VPN, provides a 99.99% SLA,
and therefore it's required to
create a pair of VPN tunnels
to achieve that SLA.
Next, the only routing
option we have for HA VPN
is dynamic via BGP.
Next, we want to
select a Cloud Router.
You can reuse the
same Cloud Router
that you were using previously
for the classic VPN BGP
tunnels.
If you'd like to create
a new Cloud Router,
however, it's not necessary.
Here, I will select the
existing Cloud Router,
and next, I will
create the tunnels.
As I select Edit
on the VPN tunnels,
you can see that
it automatically
populates the associated
interfaces from my HA VPN
gateway that was
created earlier,
and it associates the peer
gateway interfaces for me.
If you remember,
I mentioned that I
have two interfaces
for my peer gateway,
and these interfaces
have the same IP address
for the purposes of this demo.
For the first tunnel,
I will associate
interface zero of
the HA VPN gateway
with interface zero
of the peer gateway.
I'll give it a name.
Let's call it havpn-tunnel-0.
Next, you can select
the IKE version.
Most modern VPN
gateways support IKE V2,
so I'll leave it at that.
Next, enter a pre-shared key.
Now, for my example,
the pre-shared key
is going to be demovpnhavpn.
However, please note
the best practice
is to create a strong
IKE pre-shared key.
See links to our documentations
below for more information.
The Generate and copy button
here can create one for you.
Now click done.
Next, I'll configure
the second tunnel.
As you can see, this is
associated with interface one
on both the HA VPN
gateway and peer gateway.
Following the same
naming convention,
we will call this
havpn-tunnel-1.
I'll enter the same
pre-shared key and click done.
Now, once you've
configured everything,
you can click
Create and Continue.
In the next screen, we have
to configure the BGP sessions.
Let's configure the BGP session
for the first Cloud VPN tunnel.
Click Configure.
Here, I will give it a name.
Let's call it havpn-bgp-0.
Now, fill in your peer
autonomous system number.
That's what's
actually configured
on your on-premises environment.
In my environment, it's 65506.
Next, let's look at the multi
exit discriminator value
or advertiser out priority.
Because we would
like to minimize
the downtime and the
recommended configuration
as an active-active
tunnel, I know
that I've configured
my default route
priority for my classic
VPN tunnel to 100.
So I'll configure the
route priority here
to 1,000 for the HA VPN tunnel.
What this means is that
when these tunnels come up,
traffic will not
automatically switch over
to these interfaces,
because the other tunnel has
better priority.
This effectively
means that we do not
need to move traffic
to the new tunnels
until we're ready to do so.
Now, for all
configuration changes
that you would do
in the Cloud, we
would recommend them to be done
during maintenance windows.
Next, configure the Cloud
Router BGP IP and peer BGP IP.
The IPs depend on
what is configured
in your on-premises environment.
In my case, the local Cloud
Router BGP IP is 169.254.4.1,
and the BGP peer
IP is 169.254.4.2.
Next, you can configure
the advertised routes,
so you may decide to
advertise only certain routes
across this tunnel.
For the purpose of
this demonstration,
we're not going to
change the defaults,
and then we'll click
Save and Continue.
Next, configure the
second BGP session
with the desired parameters.
Here, I'll configure it with
a similar naming convention.
So here, I will
name it havpn-bgp-1.
The peer ASN is going
to be the same, 65506.
Next, under the
route priority, we'll
be putting the same MED
values so that the tunnels are
in an active-active state,
so they're essentially
able to load balanced traffic.
I will enter value
1000, the same I entered
in the other tunnel, and then
again for Cloud Router BGP
IP and BGP peer IP, this
depends on your configuration.
For me, it's 169.254.5.1, and
the peer IP is 169.254.5.2.
Now again, let's click
Save and Continue.
Finally, let's click the button
to save the BGP configuration.
Now here on step
three, we're actually
given a summary page of the
current status of our VPN
tunnels.
You can see that right
now they're establishing,
so it may take roughly 20
to 30 seconds to bring up
the tunnels, so we'll
click OK and return
to the previous page.
Now again on this page, you can
see a summary of my Cloud VPN
tunnels.
And as you can see,
my right two tunnels
are waiting for the BGP
peer to be established.
You may click Refresh here
at the top of the page,
and I'll actually
refresh the screen,
so we'll know whether the
BGP has been established.
So let's click
Refresh, and now you
can see that the
BGPs are established.
So next, if we select
the hamburger menu
at the top left hand side, and
we scroll down to VPC network,
and then under the Networking
section, we will select Routes.
Now in the Routes tab, I'm
interested in the Dynamic tab
to look at the new routes that
were learned across HA VPN.
If I click Dynamic
tab here, I can
see that I'm learning a new
IP prefix from both tunnels
with priority 1000.
Based on the other BGP routing
priority, which is set to 100,
this means that the
existing classic VPN
tunnel that I had
previously created
would still take precedence.
Recall that a lower
value is better here,
meaning that 100
wins over 1,000.
Traffic is still going to flow
across the existing VPN tunnel
and not across the
new HA VPN tunnel.
So next, as you can see here,
I have a demo virtual machine
that I'm going to
establish a ping between it
and my on-premises environment
across that VPN tunnel.
So here, I'm going to initiate
a ping to 192.168.125.1.
And as you can see,
I'm receiving packets
from that on-premises
machine, which
is located across the VPN tunnel
on my on-premises network.
So next, to have seamless
traffic failover,
let's change your
routing priorities
so that the classic
VPN tunnel has
lower priority or a higher MED
value than the HA VPNs tunnels.
So if you click on the hamburger
menu at the top left hand side,
go back to Networking, click
Hybrid Connectivity, and then
VPN, select the existing
classic VPN tunnel,
scroll down to the
Routing and Security
section, and the line item
BGP session, click Modify BGP
Session.
When the new window opens up,
change the advertised route
priority to a value larger than
what was configured for HA VPN
tunnels.
For example, my environment,
my HA VPN tunnels
have a value of 1,000.
So I'll configure the routing
priority for the classic VPN
tunnel with a value of 1,200.
Now before I click
Save and Continue,
I actually have a
on-premises router
where I need to make the
configuration changes as well.
So that traffic is symmetrical
between my HA VPN tunnel
pair and my on-premises
router and Google.
So I'll configure that
in the background,
and then I'm going to click
Save and Continue here.
So now that it's configured, if
we return to that hamburger bar
menu at the top left hand side,
scroll down to VPC network,
and select the Routes tab,
click the Dynamic tab,
and now we can see
that I'm receiving
a route from the on-premises
network with priority 1,200.
Now, this was the
priority that I configured
towards the on-prem
network as well,
so traffic is now preferring
my HA VPN tunnel pair.
If I look below
here, and I return
to my ping running in the
background, if I stop it,
I can see that traffic has
now effectively switched over
to my new HA VPN tunnel
without any interruptions.
We can see here that
we have zero packet
loss between my ping sent
from the GCP environment
to my on-premises router.
Now if I restart the ping, I can
return to my VPN configuration
under the hybrid
connectivity section.
If I select the existing
classic VPN tunnel,
I can safely delete it now.
Click Delete.
Are you sure you want
to delete this tunnel?
Click Delete.
Now since the traffic is safely
going across the HA VPN tunnel
pair, deleting the tunnel will
have no effect on my traffic.
So if I return to
the VPC Networks tab,
click the Routes button,
click the Dynamic tab,
now I can see that I'm receiving
the prefix 192.168.125.0/24
only from my HA VPN tunnel pair.
So if we go back to the
pings you're being sent,
and I stop the pings, you
can see effectively I've
had zero packet
loss now that I've
removed my classic VPN tunnel.
And with that, we have
now a successful migration
from classic VPN over to HA VPN.
That concludes the first
migration path from classic VPN
utilizing BGP to HA VPN.
Section two, migrate an existing
classic VPN utilizing policy
based VPN to HA VPN between
two projects or VPCs
within Google Cloud.
Now in this section, we'll look
at configuring HA VPN tunnels
between two projects in GCP.
This migration path
is used to migrate
classic VPN tunnels
between two projects in GCP
to HA VPN tunnels.
Let's click the hamburger menu
at the top left hand side.
Let's scroll down to Networking,
select Hybrid Connectivity,
click the VPN tab, and
here, as you can see,
I have established a classic
VPN policy based tunnel.
If I scroll to the
right, you can see here
that there is no dynamic
routes configured,
and it's completely
policy based,
meaning I manually configured
my traffic selectors
and traffic is going
between this VPC
and project to another
project and VPC within GCP.
Now, if I open
this new window, I
can show you I have
another project.
And in this project, I will go
to the same Hybrid Connectivity
section and the VPN tab
and show you the tunnels
that I have created.
You can see here I have
a existing classic VPN
tunnel, which is policy based.
If I scroll to the right, you
can see that it's established.
You can also see here that I
have existing tunnels created
because we're going to
do the configuration only
in one project, so I've already
configured my HA VPNs here
in this project.
We will now create HA VPN
tunnels to the new project
instead of to an
on-premises network.
Going back to the
original project,
I'll create a new
pair of HA VPN tunnels
by selecting Create VPN Tunnel.
I will then select the
HA VPN demo gateway
that I've created before
and click Continue.
So in this case, we'll
select a Peer VPN gateway
type of Google
Cloud, and here I'll
be presented with a list of
projects that I have access to,
and I'll select the
project that I'm
attempting to create a
connection to by selecting
the VPN gateway name.
Now, as you recall since I've
already created an HA VPN
gateway in the
other project, this
is something that you would have
had to do prior to the step.
So you would simply
follow similar steps
that I've shown you earlier
on how to create an HA VPN
gateway, and you would
do that in one project
before the other.
Now once I select
the gateway name,
here I'm presented with the
high availability options.
Again, very similar from
the previous section.
Here, we will create
a pair of VPN tunnels
again to provide
high availability
with a four nines of SLA.
Next, I will select my
existing Cloud routers.
Again, you can create a new
one, but it's not necessary.
And now once I click
the VPN tunnels,
you can see that they've
already been pre-associated
one to one with the interfaces
of my peer VPN gateway.
Now, this is done automatically
for you within Google Cloud.
Now again, similar to
before, let's give it a name.
I'm going to call it
havpn-peer-project-0.
Next, the same configuration
for IKE version.
If you want, you
can change that.
Next, enter a pre-shared key.
Now again, a strong
pre-shared key is recommended.
See links for our documentation
below for more information,
but for this demo, I'm going to
select a simple pre-shared key.
Once entered, I click Done.
Next, I'm going to
configure my second tunnel.
By selecting this tunnel,
let's give it a name.
I'm going to name it
havpn-peer-project-1.
Next, I'm going to enter the
same pre-shared key again.
Click Done, then
Create and Continue.
On this page, we'll
create the BGP sessions.
I've already created
exactly the same thing here
in my other projects, so I'm
only going to do it here.
Let's click Configure
and give it a name.
So in my example,
it's havpn-peer-0.
Peer ASN in my case is 65507.
And now for the
route priorities,
it'll be a little bit different
than the previous example,
because policy based routes
have a default priority
in Google Cloud of 1,000.
So let's create a
route priority that's
higher than the policy
based route, so a lower
numerical value, as you recall.
So I will enter 100, which
is lower than the 1,000,
and then I'll enter the relevant
Cloud Router and BGP router
peer IPs.
My Cloud Router
IP is 169.254.7.1,
and my Peers is 169.254.7.2.
Please note once again that
all changes should be done
during maintenance windows.
Click Save and Continue.
Let's configure the
second BGP session.
Click Configure.
Again, enter a name.
I'm going to name
it havpn-peer-1.
And again, enter your ASN.
In my case, it's 65507.
The multi exit discriminator
will be the same as before,
so for me it's 100.
Then configure the appropriate
Cloud Router and BGP peer IPs.
In my environment, it's
169.254.8.1 and 169.254.8.2.
Again, click save and continue.
Now, I won't click Save
BGP Configuration just yet,
and that's because
I'd like to show
traffic is currently going
across the existing classic VPN
tunnel.
And here, I'm going to
initiate a ping from my VM.
The IP address of my peers
projects VM is 10.30.30.2.
So I'm going to leave
the ping running.
I can now click Save
BGP configuration.
Now here on this page, we
get the BGP summary page
that you've seen previously.
You can click OK at the bottom.
Here you can see the
newly created tunnels,
and you can see the peer
VPN gateway and the project
that it's associated with.
If we scroll to the right, we
can see the current BGP session
status.
If we click Refresh, we can see
the BGP peers are established.
Click on the hamburger menu
at the top left hand side
and scroll down to VPC network
and select the Routes tab.
Next, select the Dynamic
tab, and now we can see
a destination range
of 10.30.30.0/24,
which is a new route that
was created across the HA VPN
peers.
If I click the All tab, I can
see a policy based drought
tunnel with priority 1,000 for
the same prefix, 10.30.30.0/24.
Now, traffic has automatically
moved over to the HA VPN pair
across these two
priority 100 link.
So if we return to
the Dynamic tab,
again, you can see these
two priority 100 link,
and traffic is effectively moved
over to the HA VPN tunnels.
If I return to my VM
window down below,
I can now stop
the pings, and you
can see that traffic has
seamlessly switched over
without any packet loss.
I can then
reestablish the pings,
go back to my VPN
section, and simply
select the VPN policy based
routing tunnel and delete it.
So again, let's go back
to the hamburger bar menu,
let's scroll down to Hybrid
Connectivity and VPN,
select the classic
VPN policy based
routing tunnel, click Delete.
Are you sure you want
to delete this tunnel?
Click Delete.
And there you have it.
We only have HA VPNs tunnel
left, so the last thing to do
is to delete the
existing classic VPN
gateways unless you're using
them for any other tunnels.
But if you're not, you
can safely delete them.
Now if we go back to my VM
ping running here below,
you can see that if
I stop it, there's
been no packet loss when
a tunnel was deleted.
So I can return to
my Cloud console,
scroll down to the VPC
network sections and routes,
and you can see
here in the All tab,
I no longer see the policy based
route VPN tunnel for prefix
10.30.30.0/24, and they're
only still being learned via
the dynamic routes
in the Dynamic tab.
And with that, this
concludes this video.
I've posted some useful
links to our documentation
below which explain various
topologies and configurations
with HA VPN.
Thank you, and have a great day.
[MUSIC PLAYING]